um a lot of new information has come out
in regards to the uh tragedy that
happened in astroworld as well as travis
scott
and me having looked up a lot of this
information people asked me what my
thoughts are whether my thoughts have
changed and let me tell you i am now 100
sure that travis scott bears zero
responsibility i mean this man really
no joke of course
i was like
these people they lose their [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] there's blood on your
hands breathe okay
what i think is really important to this
that i don't think it's referenced
enough and i think it's like really
damning in a way live nation was behind
this event they were the ones who were
organizing vast majority of it in
working with travis scott and their
company has a horrendous record they are
linked to over 200 deaths at their
events over 750 injuries as well as
dozens of safety violations at their
music events now we have to ask
ourselves
now one can say that travis may bear a
lot of blame because the fact that he
worked with the largest
largest live events company in the world
but
at the same time
these people need to be held to account
as well travis has two prior incidents
in regards to inciting people at his
shows one happened in 2015. travis scott
plead guilty to reckless conduct charges
placed under court super division for
one year encouraged fans to mosh pit at
lollapalooza in chicago and he
encouraged them to vault over the
security barriers
[Music]
[Applause]
let's go
he's telling security get the [ __ ] back
don't touch the people volting over the
fence
[Music]
two three
rogers arkansas travis scott's accused
again of inciting a riot urging crowd
members to rush the stage several people
were injured arrested and pled guilty to
disorderly conduct and
ordered to pay court fees and
restitution to the people
to 200 people and then once again bird's
eye view tour in new york city
fan kyle green injured and left
paralyzed after jumping off a balcony
travis scott yelled to him i see you but
are you gonna do it
has he near the edge of the railing
they're gonna catch you don't be scared
don't be scared
the man did it and ended up becoming
paralyzed kyle filed a lawsuit against
travis what
maybe it's because i'm able to be like
no i'm not gonna [ __ ] jump off the
[ __ ] rail
and i do it it's stupid to me i
understand that you have some kind of
responsibility but you're on a legend
they're gonna catch you gonna catch you
jump it's like why would you trust him
like what does he know
why did you joan i was like why why
because he asked cause he's travis and
you ask
okay more than that
there's hundreds of thousands of people
all surrounding you everyone's looking
at you you're not used to that limelight
your favorite artist tells you to do
something you're gonna do it porn abba
they'll tell you go on twerk then they
go torque point speed don't feel me this
brings us to this year's astro world and
now obviously now you've got 50 000
people there's a huge show happening
travis is yelling at the crowd it's high
energy look travis's shows are always
like that apparently from what i've been
able to read up on his shows are high
energy it's very like anarchist type of
a vibe people love the idea of being
violent and rowdy at the shows and
undoubtedly when you love that
rebellious energy and when you're
telling people to jump over barricades
where you tell people to rush the stage
yeah people are going to get hurt as
much as you want to show people a great
experience people's safety and
well-being also matters throughout the
whole experience you have to understand
that and you have to be responsible for
that if i was security i was at the
event organized i'd be suing the [ __ ]
out of travis for things like that
putting my people my staff in danger
because he wants to create a hype moment
have people jump over that's crazy
that's crazy
if you're one of those security guards
you set up that ring that perimeter for
safety reasons you do it not just for
your safety for the people in the back
because people who are jumping over that
railing are now close to you if they got
weapons if they got whatever it puts
everybody in danger there's a different
kind of negligence that comes in when i
see that kind of stuff so you have that
entire history and you come to this
event and you constantly encourage that
kind of energy it carries over and now
you have people in an extra vulnerable
seat go ahead i'm from both perspective
from the perspective of a performer that
performs on stage not from the
perspective of a of a security guard
that has to face that
there's a lot of nightmares that
security guards
at these show's face
and that is not talked about when an
artist
when another decide to go in the crowd
prior to that you have to you have to
ask the security you have to or be in
contact with the security so that we
know what the [ __ ] is going on we have
to mobilize people because a lot of
things happen you know whenever there's
people um there's people
at
events that are artists at event that
are uh complaining about well they
snatch my shame and stuff like that and
i look at the footage and the person's
like i'mma go in the crowd because i'm
close to my people and they go in the
crowd yes these things happen and stuff
like that so you have to be you have to
be in in in um
you have to talk with the security i
looked up after the video we did i
looked up a couple of uh a couple of
shows there's a couple of instances
where the show of travis where he says
to people to [ __ ] [ __ ] up i'm not saying
that the people there have do not have a
responsibility but that's his show he's
telling people the [ __ ] up there's his
there's he has a responsibility for that
no it's not so much a control that you
have people have accountability yet
people don't have to necessarily do it
but there's this crowd effect that's
happening that you have
so he definitely has responsibility like
that you know when you ask people to go
on a crowded move a certain way yes
there's there's this whole thing this
whole thing where you're supposed to
emcee the crowd where you're supposed to
be the master of ceremony you're
supposed to entertain the crowd and
stuff like that but there's some things
that especially in the in in
hip-hop
there's a lot of things like that that
happen that that can go overboard i'm
thinking about hip-hop yes you know
democrats and stuff like that but i've
seen
shows from
slipknot which is another band that the
that does metal that it goes it goes
out of hand
because it's like a moment that you want
to replicate that it's anarchy and you
want to replicate all that and it's all
based and fun and everything and stuff
you as an artist you pack your [ __ ] you
go home and that's it but people in the
crowd just want to watch the show don't
unless they want to
want to do that i've seen another show i
don't want to put people out there but
i've seen another show where i was again
i was outside of the people in the
middle and
the artist on top
asked people to mock spit open a circle
this side and this side you're gonna run
against each other i've seen that in in
in concert so yeah there's definitely
it's your name on the brand it's you on
the stage you have some and you do
certain things to the crowd like that
you asked the crowd to
vault over or whatever
there's going to be some kind of
responsibilities you're going to have to
have
with that it's a mess it's a whole mess
but one thing i think is a giant mistake
whenever things like these happen right
there's such an emphasis put on the big
name star
at all times right this guy's the face
of it bang bang
and i think it doesn't do justice to the
people who really suffered because
accountability means putting the blame
where it needs to be appropriately not
where it's most convenient we say travis
scott because he's the name and he's the
big person and if he pays then we can
all see some change happen when i can
assure you when you work a big show like
that travis scott doesn't know [ __ ]
about the security travis shot doesn't
know [ __ ] about the layout of the whole
thing they are never briefed on these
things they hire other people who handle
it now of course when you hire people
you're always going to have some level
of accountability but understand there's
people who 150 percent failed at their
job
failed when the police department
declares that there is a mass casualty
at this place
immediately that information needs to be
relayed to live nation who was in charge
of this festival right
and they need to just cut the plug
because you are trusting other people to
handle their parts if there's a
disturbance on the left wing and there's
a mass stabbing the artist is not going
to know he's counting on security to
figure that out and then they're
supposed to relate to him cut the plug
right now that doesn't mean that travis
doesn't have accountability we've said
throughout this whole thing 100 there's
a large measure of it but you have to
understand there are failures
systematically at every level that
happened when something like this
happens and to levy it on travis to put
all the focus on him doesn't injustice
to the people who've really suffered
because the people who are really really
at fault are not going to get held up as
accountability should be
so we as people when we're watching this
cannot just look at the big name person
to
be levied all the blame we have to look
at yo live nation it reminds me a bit of
the r kelly situation where all the
emphasis would pronounce kelly not
recognizing that the only reason they
were able to get our kelly was all
who assisted him in his crimes who were
able to get off scot-free in order to
put him to the sword enabler you have to
ask yourself did we just let go of a
whole bunch of criminals just because we
want to get the big name one you feel
what i'm saying
man there's a lot of other people who
were involved in this who enabled it who
facilitated the young women right like
you know the thing is it actually works
like that in the legal system yes
unfortunately yes because the process
yeah we'll drop you every we'll drop all
this we'll drop all this all this give
me the big name that's right give me the
big name give me the big boss and i'll
be able to do something for you because
the prosecution also likes
likes all of that yeah they like all the
fame they're like congratulations mm-hmm
but it's a big deal i'm the one who got
r kelly yeah
and i'm also gonna say this
while we're having this whole discussion
you also have to place a tremendous
amount of accountability on the people
who didn't seem to give a [ __ ] about
other folks who were dying right next to
them
yes
the people who didn't have enough
consideration to try to make a path for
people who were suffering the folks who
wanted to be more concerned with raging
than their own neighbors there's also a
certain amount of accountability there i
think when it comes to these kind of
events we always look to creators we
always look to the organizers
undoubtedly they deserve some measure of
accountability this if not the lion's
share but u.s individuals also have to
say you played a role in that
when someone's struggling right next to
you falling to the ground and you just
being concerned about trying to get as
close to the stage as possible you play
a part in that
we can't always look upwards in regards
we can also look sideways
because i can assure you put in a
different crowd with a different set of
people the results could have been
drastically different
what i mean
not all crowds would have behaved like
that
irrespective of what artist is on stage
fair
you think what i'm saying yeah i
understand a lot of people act
completely differently based off what
kind of crowd we know this you know i
know this because we go to night clubs
the crowd changes
right you could have the same dj
depending on who shows up right so you
also have to look at that there well
sorry and it's hard to do that and it's
not nearly as interesting or
there's no like catharsis because it's
just a sea of people right there's it's
a question mark you don't have any faces
try to disguise the face and then you
can point to and you can twitter at
but the individuals also
have to ask themselves like what's going
on here dude you know what's crazy maybe
this is also just me
what the [ __ ] is a 10 year old doing at
a concert like that am i crazy
um you're old you're old and immigrant
my parents would have never instead
the first time i went to a concert i was
old old you understand yeah 10 years old
cook yeah it's his favorite artist and
stuff like that yeah
there's people that bring their kids
listen to each day on working in concert
working
you know i did a whole bunch of jobs
right you already know that got to pay
the bills you got it you know and
yeah
i remembered it was ashiaga there was
one time i was working at ashiaga i was
serving alcohol you know the
[ __ ] are passing through the
crowd with the alcohol like that yeah
kids yeah eminem was on stage
kids
eminem has it
the amount the amount of people that
listen to eminem ranges from small to
very old and but the lyrics i'm like
goddamn yeah you know i mean uh [ __ ] but
there were there was kids i i'd have to
ask myself
why why eminem it's just like when you
know it was all cute that little girl
that went to ellen's show and she was
from the uk her with a friend that
doesn't talk right and they were a big
fan of nicki minaj and everybody was
like oh that's so cute and i was like
it's like that's not the only saying
song that that nicki minaj thinks you
know and nicki minaj has a song about
anaconda
to me it's not even the content of the
music though to me it's the environment
of that festival where people are laced
with all kinds of drugs and you guys
might not understand this but festivals
are
abundant with
people overdosing
dealers who are present right that's why
do you think they have all those
paramedics there
why do you think they have all those
base because americans are not really
healthy
wrong answer
it's because people are popping stuff oh
and you add overheating right
dehydration to that
it's a deadly cocktail the first thing
is the first thing is sun then there's
heat
then there's alcohol
but not in that order so
why kids it's like you wouldn't bring
kids to a bar but you're going to go to
a music festival it's like i won't it's
funny because what i would i wouldn't go
in a festival
outside
like i have a feeling that people don't
pop pills as much inside and outside i
will go if there's a concert and it's
like in a closed venue like like an
arena and stuff like that and i don't
have i could get tickets with my kid
like
above and we could see that like justin
timberlake and stuff like that or
whatever but outside it's a different
vibe
it's a dif people smoke all kinds of
things and people pop more than inside i
think i believe yeah man there's crazy
footage out there the whole thing but
anyways i'm not going to stay too long
on this let us know what you guys think
in the comments below who do you think
most of the blame goes to should kids be
a lot of these festivals what about live
nation why is there more conversation
about that is our assessment wrong let
us know why we want to hear from you
guys